loads of people have talked about the
international standard cup of tea and
there are hundreds of clickbait articles
describing it or ranting about how it's
the wrong way to make tea and there are
lengthy infographics videos talking
about it but as far as I can tell no one
has actually made a standard cup of tea
for the internet before and there are a
couple of reasons for that one you have
to either buy a copy of the standard or
visit a library that subscribes to the
standards online so you can write down
the details and - it requires specialist
equipment most people in Britain make
their tea by putting a teabag in a mug
and then pouring boiling water on it if
you want to be fancy then you take a pre
warmed tea pot and you put some
loose-leaf tea in it like this stuff and
then you brew the tea in there and then
you pour the results through a strainer
into a cup it's fancy but the standard
iso 31000 3 doesn't ask for any of that
instead it uses a bit of equipment that
most people won't even have heard of
which is a professional tea tasting set
now the standard describes it in more
technical terms diagrams and
requirements of construction and weight
and size and volume but fortunately I
could just buy a set that match the
standard and the instructions for it are
actually pretty simple you measure out
two grams of tea per hundred milliliters
of water plus or minus 2% so for this
that means 2 point 8 grams plus or minus
point zero five grams which I worked out
in advance because it took ages to get
it that precise and then you combine
that with either local or standardized
water depending on what you're testing
by filling this little mug to the bottom
of those serrations also you let it
steep for six minutes which seems a bit
long but hey that's a standard
6 minutes are up you separate the liquor
as it's called and the tea leaves by
pouring it through the little serrations
here into this cup let's see if I can do
it no I can't but close enough they say
that if you're adding milk you should
put it in first but this is green tea so
I'm not getting involved in that debate
you drill it through there most of the
leaves stay in the cup and once it's
drained you can inspect the tea leaves
and then you drink it not from the
traditional cup but from the bulb there
was a separate standard ISO 1839 on how
you actually sample it and what you
report and it tastes tastes ok it's it's
just ok because the standard isn't meant
to make the perfect cup of tea or the
most british cup of tea every time the
fact that there's a standard for tea
does the rounds of the internet loads of
people misunderstand it as being
prescriptive and saying everyone should
make their tea this way and they really
shouldn't ISO 31000 3 is meant to make
an okay but reproducible cup of tea it
sets out instructions so that whoever
and wherever you are you can create the
same cup of tea as someone else in
another time and place for regular tea
at home make it however you want to
stick a teabag in a mug put the milk in
first or last use fancy China if you
want make your team days in advance and
then warm it up again in the microwave
don't don't do that but it doesn't
matter there is no perfect cup of tea
there is only the right one for you this
here this isn't perfect definitely isn't
perfect but as far as I can tell this is
the first international standard cup of
tea on the Internet I don't actually
like tea